Hi ihr Lieben! Wir machen heute einen No-Bake Blechkuchen.
das werden..wie soll ich sie überhaupt nennen? Ich weiß es gar nicht!
Ich möchte jetzt nicht Dickmann's-Schnitten - nee, so möchte ich sie nicht nennen!
es sind..ich glaube Stracciatella-Schnitten!
weil wir nehmen als Basis Dickmann's weil ich die noch übrig hatte.
Meine Schwester hatte Geburtstag, hat zu viel eingekauft und hat mir die dann mitgegeben für ein Rezept.
Und die Schokolade, die in der Außenhülle hier sich befindet, die wird gleich zerstückelt und dann haben wir so eine Art Stracciatella-Creme.
Aber als Allererstes nehme ich hier die Waffel weg. Die brauchen wir jetzt nicht für die Creme
die werde ich aber nicht wegschmeißen. Die kommt hier zu meinen anderen Keksen für den Boden. Dazu sage ich euch aber gleich noch was!
So und ich mache das hier - ich hab viel geredet merke ich gerade! -
aber ich erledige das hier und dann sehen wir uns gleich wieder!
(H: Und die Zutaten?)
Die Zutaten findet ihr wie immer in der Videobeschreibung.
Hier unter dem Titel.
(H: Yes!)
So, hier unten habe ich jetzt Karamellkekse - da könntet ihr jetzt auch Butterkekse oder Kakaokekse nehmen -
und hier oben die Waffeln weil ich die einfach nicht verschwenden wollte.
So und jetzt mixe ich das Ganze und gebe da geschmolzene Butter dazu.
So, jetzt ist quasi der No-Bake Boden fertig und ich hab' jetzt hier meinen Backrahmen
und ich mache das ganz gerne so, dass ich meinen eckigen Tortenretter als Boden benutze.
Ihr könnten den Backrahmen jetzt auch direkt auf irgendeine Servierplatte legen, das ist auch kein Problem
aber ich find' das halt mega praktisch. Ich hab' den Griff, ich kann das direkt anfassen und in den Kühlschrank tun und und und!
Verlinke ich euch auch unten in die Infobox.
Ich hab' jetzt meinen Backrahmen auf ca. 22x24cm eingestellt.
Ein paar Zentimeter Unterschied, das ist überhaupt kein Problem. Gerade bei so No-Bake Geschichten nicht!
So und jetzt gebe ich den Boden einmal hier in die Backform und drück den schön fest an.
Den Boden ganz kurz zur Seite legen, ich zeig' euch jetzt die schnelle Creme!
Dafür nehme ich mir hier die Schaumküsse oder die Dickmann's in meiner Schüssel,
werde sie jetzt richtig schön mit meinem Teigschaber zermatschen/ein bisschen kleindrücken.
Und da gebe ich dann Quark dazu, ich nehme jetzt Magerquark. Ihr könntet auch z.B. den 20-prozentigen nehmen, das wäre hier gar kein Problem.
Und ich nehme gleich auch noch Schmand dazu und Vanilleextrakt.
Und dann muss ich erstmal nach den Geschmack schauen ob ich überhaupt noch Puderzucker brauche weil die Dickmann's sind ja schon sehr süß.
So, mal probieren!
Mmh, süß genug!
(H: *kichert*)
Also gerade so richtig. Der Quark nimmt so diese extreme Süße von den Dickmann's - perfekt!
Jetzt binde ich das noch so ein bisschen mit Sahnefest und dann ist die Creme auch schon fertig.
Und ich hab' noch nicht mal irgendeine Maschine gebraucht! Also anfängerfreundlich, freundlich für Menschen, die vielleicht keine Küchenmaschine haben - perfekt!
(H: Und ohne Strom!)
Ohne Strom, also man spart sogar Geld bei dem Rezept!
Ich muss es nochmal betonen: Ich liebe diese Winkelpalette! Die wurde exakt nach meinen Vorstellungen kreiert, die habe ich mitentwickelt.
Und die kommt immer so gut vorne mit der Spitze an den Backrahmen und hier hinten mit dem Winkel.
Jetzt habe ich das perfekt verstrichen. Jetzt kommt das aber in den Kühlschrank für mindestens 4h, gerne auch über Nacht.
Also ihr könnt's auch länger drin lassen. Wir haben's jetzt 17h deshalb würde ich mal sagen: Bevor wir um 21h weiterfilmen Hamza, machen wir für heute Schluss und dann seht ihr uns morgen einfach wieder!
Also bei mir kommt der jetzt die ganze Nacht in den Kühlschrank. Und dann lasse ich mir um ehrlich zu sein noch was einfallen! Ich überlege gerade:
Mache ich einen Schokoabschluss, mache ich vielleicht einen Früchteabschluss? Überlege ich mir bis morgen!
(H: Brainstorming ist angesagt!
Wir brainstormen! Dieses Rezept ist übrigens sehr spontan entstanden
und mit Zutaten, die ich einfach Zuhause hatte. Da seht ihr mal: Es kann auch wirklich einfach sein und mit ganz ganz einfachen Mitteln auch!
(H: Einfach kreativ sein!)
Genau! Also, wir sehen uns dann morgen, Tschuuss!
1 Tag später: Ich hab' mich jetzt für eine Schokoglasur entschieden. Eine Mischung aus Vollmilch- und weißer Kuvertüre,
die habe ich bei niedriger Wattzahl ganz einfach in der Mikrowelle geschmolzen.
Und damit das gleich nicht so knackt sondern sich ganz schön geschmeidig durchschneiden lässt,
gebe ich da noch ein bisschen Kokosfett dazu..also ganz einfach einrühren.
Und dann hoffe ich, dass ich ein schönes Muster hinkriege!
So, im nächsten Schritt die Glasur kurz trocknen lassen - das dauert keine 10min - dann den Backformlöser nehmen,
den Rand schön rauslösen und jetzt nehme ich den Backrahmen einmal weg.
So, die Klemmungen lösen.. und ich finde, dass das Rezept echt mega mega schnell ging!
Mal gucken...so. Ja, schön! Sehr schön!
Jetzt gucken wir, ob der Geschmackstest auch bestanden ist. Denn wenn nicht, dann wird dieses Video niemals erscheinen!
Aber ich glaube, das schmeckt. Ich glaube das schmeckt!
(H: Kiki bei dir hat noch nie was nicht geschmeckt!)
Ohh! Wir machen jetzt kurz die letzten Szenen und dann schneide ich den an und dann probiere ich!
(H: *lacht* Ich probiere?)
Wir beide probieren!
Äh..kommst du mal bitte?!
(H: Was denn?)
Kommst du mal bitte? Wir haben gesagt wir probieren zusammen.
Nein Hamza, wir haben gesagt wir probieren zusammen!
Willst du jetzt vor laufender Kamera dein Versprechen -
(H: Ja und wer nimmt das auf jetzt?)
Die Kam- das Stativ!
Ist die Kamera am Laufen?
Okay, wir verkosten jetzt unsere Schnitte!
(H: Boah zum ersten Mal stehe ich hier und ess mit dir! Heftig ey!)
Jaa!
Ich bin - ich gehe jetzt ohne Erwartungen da ran, okay? Hier, du kannst von hier das Stück abmachen.
Ich bin richtig gespannt!
(H: Also das ist jetzt ein Dickmann's-Kuchen quasi?)
Das sind Dickmann's-Schnitten. Sollen wir's Dickmann's-Schnitten nennen oder habt ihr andere Vorschläge?
Und wie schmeckt's?
(H: Mmmh, ich find's Hammer!)
Mmmh! Mmmh!
(H: Es hat auch ein bisschen einen sauren Touch, ne?)
M-hm, durch den Quark. Aber der schmeckt jetzt nicht schwer.
Also der schmeckt jetzt nicht so, dass man sagt: "Boah, der haut richtig auf die Hüften!"
Also das tut er bestimmt. Der schmeckt richtig gut, ich bin glücklich!
(H: *lacht* Der eindeutige Beweis, dass Kuchen glücklich macht!)
Mmmh!
Kuchen macht immer glücklich!
(H: #backenmachtglücklich)
Hamza ich bin jetzt dafür, dass du dein Stück kriegst und ich das Stück. Weil ganz ehrlich ey: Das Stück teilen..
muss jetzt nicht sein!
(H: Ich bin dafür, dass ich mein Stück jetzt auf Instagram bisschen promote und die Leute bisschen heiß drauf mache!)
Das kannst du gut! Hamza ist richtig fies auf Instagram.
Ich mach' mir jetzt auch noch 'nen Kaffee dazu.
(H: Auf jeden Fall.)
Okay. Unbedingt nachmachen!
Das Video geht somit online!
Es bleibt nicht im Verborgenen.
(H: Auf jeden Fall!)
Es schmeckt sehr gut, ich würd' auch nichts dran ändern.
Denkt bitte dran, dass ihr den im Kühlschrank lasst und kurz vorm Servieren erst rausholt.
Das ist das Einzige, das ich euch als Tipp geben kann.
Also ganz viel Spaß beim Nachmachen!
Hamza du darfst-
(H: Vergesst nicht, zu abonnieren!)
Genau, du darfst das Outro machen!
(H: Vergesst nicht, zu liken!)
(H: Und ähm.. ja, wir sehen uns beim nächsten Rezept! Tschüss, eure Kiki!)
*beide lachen*
Korb!
(H: Achso!)
Ich hab so gemacht!
Mann Hamza, das musst du rausschneiden jetzt!
(H: *lügt* Okay!)